[Musica]
nelle puntate precedenti di un mese
identità ma me lo ricordo il jump scheri
invece no niente rossano come credo
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovi
dio sono fa vj e ci siamo l'episodio 2
di residenti vol
let's go adesso ragazza ecco quella era
la parte della deve adesso non so
proprio niente di quello che trovo per
quanto norma in anche la parte della
demo ho fatto cose assurde
non sapevo neanche quella sapevo tutto
bello allegro non ci dovrebbero essere
zombie teoricamente perché qua chi è che
ci ha avuto accesso andiamo sotto scala
sotterranei e simpatico e un altro
ascensore di qua marcava così com'era
allora cosa per incastonarsi la gemma
cos'è e un micro 1 cos'è non lo so come
un'arma comunque ho chiuso
no no no no sono quelli che strisciano
no no quella fare lì è imbattibile
sai quello che penso non lo faccio mai
ragazzi quella fare lì è inguardabile e
sgravi non mi ricordo neanche come si
chiamano tra l'altro danno non è quelli
cosi ti chiamiamo cosi messing eccolo a
no non è l'unica
questo è veramente brutto ma brutto che
cazzo
sei bellissimo lo sta sbattendo per
terra saputo dire oh mio dio ce la fai a
correre tipo correre con le gambe
corriamo
eh si io lo lascerei neanche a me
infatti andrai via è veramente un boss
questo che la boss fight figo capito
perché ho trovato degli oggetti quindi
niente spacchiamo gli la faccia che vedo
così ciao giovanni marco demonio solo in
un vicolo cieco
eccoli perfetto merz è così volevo
giocare io è successo all occhio
all'occhio via via via via
mamma mia che faccenda brutta proprio
contro di lui ti dovevi mettere poi la
donna ragazzi perché poi non rischiare
ora cavate velocissimo questa nuova
cavolo eva per quanto corre
volendo posso usare anche fucile a pompa
e che non sono tanto
no ho rischiato quanti complimenti per
la mira lorenzo e non aver mai finito
vabbè regalo mandato è sceso dove doveva
finito non l'ho visto porca vacca 8
al tipo ha detto aiutatemi come faccio
aiutati se stai tentando di spaccarmi
con quella fare lì spiega il rischio
rischio a madonna che botta sto
veramente rischiando il sacco però sono
bravissimo francesco v riguardo andare
via non andare perché te ne vai che poi
devi saltare in faccia puoi morire tipo
c'è un punto in cui mori anche tu ok non
ho più pure quindi o schiatti o schiatti
ancora e basta puoi morire tipo morire
morire
bravo suicidi di un'ora e mezza di boss
fight sono quasi morto tra bravo lio che
la scala ha visto tutto il combattimento
ha capito che sono forte ed è scesa da
sola la scala
sono curioso di vedere dove mi porta non
si scaricano perché c'è veramente i
sotterranei fanno sono bruttissimi
almeno poi tratto sto morendo qui magari
zero sta roba qua e là c'era qualcosa
che non ho visto tipo sicuro posso
valutare qualcosa tipo eh vabbè cosa
stavo perdendo qua armadietto ottimo
aiutatemi gigante
pensiero e lenti a contatto per cosa
fare lì come le trovi questa roba se
stai facendo quattro ha spostato il
ponte che sono proprio l'aggiustatutto
amo e che mi stavo osservando se non è
passato di qua scusami per messing
niente posso salvare grazie a dio il
borsello in più
very good alla conoscenza di uomini
belli già fatta abbiamo trovato le
persone giuste per cui passare del tempo
adesso magari andiamo dalla gnocca ecco
tutto questo claire dov'è finita visto
che è sparita dal mondo il cui scopo per
strada e il parcheggio della polizia
questo cioè tu spiegami che cosa ci
faceva quel tipo nella fogna della
polizia
va beh a meno che non ci sia qualcuno
qui fuori che tenta di entrare tipo
adesso
inserisci il parcheggio serve la tessera
o ciò che ci sta canino lì un cane mica
bello tra l'altro però dimenticato che
c'è un i cani zona ecco magari la
pistola voleva che ha in mano se mai ci
venisse in mente è quella che aveva in
mano ottimizzarla adesso non ho
grazie fratello chi è chimica e claire
lo fai ti ha salvato dei punti
mi scusi grazie che bella una
conversazione così continua a sparare al
cane nel mentre che parlano che succede
qui beh socievole la zia a si vede anche
io se ne aveva finito
spero mi chiude la porta e poi non si
apre più se non si apre me ne vado giuro
aperta andate in un nanosecondo come ha
fatto uscire di qua mi servirebbe eccoli
qua i colpi ni ma così non mappa
centrale di polizia ma è infatti dice ma
non rientra nella centrale di polizia
così cioè dove ero stato già prima può
essere alle celle salve salve buongiorno
stia lì e per carità ci sono proprio le
celle tutte le celle sotterranee che
figo va bene non ho idea di dove sia
finita la zia
però secondo me tra un po premere un
tasto che mi farà aprire tutte le c'è a
questo non è uno zombie sembra anche mio
zio tra un essere umano e facciamo bacio
tirami fuori e ti do questo è l'unico
modo per uscire dal parcheggio fidati
scusa non posso farlo devo parlarne col
commissario
sì
siamo entrambi i prigionieri qui quindi
o collaboriamo e riusciamo a uscire
merda
arriva cosa chi è che sta arrivando non
ho la chiave
secondo me melo de monetizza nostro
video
il problema è come apro questa porta non
lavano alla aprirò mai che così che
uscito da li regalava beh devo aprire la
porta non so come va bene orca vecchio
mi dimentico ci sono gli zombie nella
porte
basta che chimiche come faccio arrivare
in quella cella li devo devo aprirli in
qualche modo ma non so come devo trovare
il quadro elettrico
sono contento che sia sempre più allegro
sto posto comunque permesso salve quadri
elettrici per cortesia anche velocemente
prima che che figo e un poligono di tiro
potrei sprecare tutti i miei colpi qua
mag e caccia il procione sparo si sparò
sti cosi qua guadagno dei bo cioè sono
dei collezionabili tipo out che ho visto
un procione che ballava erano iraq un
volevo dire ora per me sting addirittura
devo aprire ste robe
spero che non esca niente di strano
giuro un oggetto ci sarà sicuro anche un
tizio in realtà se ti alzi tiri metto
dentro quindi venivate un po la chiave
thank you lo sapevo che si sarebbe
alzato lo sapevo aiuto
ai giochi possono lui che ci fa un altro
lì da dove è riuscito ad un uscito
questo è uscita se le potete morire per
favore morire
sapete cosa vuol dire morire potete
morire per cortesia grazie gentili
un'ora e mezza ad ammazza la gente via
alla chiave l'ho trovata perfetto tra
l'altro sono quasi convinto che se
questa qua la ritengo la butto dentro
sono così convinto con questa chiave qua
se accendo poi tutta la corrente c'è tra
mi fa ritornare nella polinelli
distretto di polizia dove all'inizio
sono quasi convinto di questo ma la
pianta blu e la pianta rossa insieme che
creano la pianta del bologna non ho
capito il seno non so cosa serve alla
pianta blog prof
ok ho aperto tutto tranne gola con gli
scarafaggi benissimo via simpatico
comunque ho la chiave
beh non mi ricordo dove la porta ma ora
ecco tipo qua dietro sta serranda suo
nome rientro nel distretto quasi sicuro
è tratto la possa aprire la via della
famiglia per il distretto quasi sicuro
che non riapre convinto e giusto
un tornato dove penso di esser tornato
no per niente scherzavano ritornare nel
distretto di polizia o sbagliato
buongiorno scatto la componente
elettrica bene e qualche cosa
dell'elettricità secondo me a occhio e
croce
eccolo che cosa la corrente mortacci sua
6 ore dall
hera è stato così semplice azionari così
la corrente solo questo devo fare vedi
che la possa aprire sta roba qua non
avevo capito chiave una chiave molto
consumata questa qua e la chiave della
della macchina
quindi io adesso esco e vado ad aprire
la macchina perciò una macchina sicuro
che possa aprire postali acceso non di
più non agonistica e cioè la stessa
capacità di osservazione di un
coleottero deceduto
non ho mai capito perché la volante la a
molto easy era questa cavo davanti che
culo o giu il calcio della matilda
veramente matilde questa attività
semitica sta diventando un fucile di
precisione st pistola vabbè che figata
averi che si è spento sto pezzente
allora secondo me hanno li devo fare
andare sul rosso a ditelo a caso
accendere il giusto
non ho capito cosa ho fatto però un
futuro la elettrotecnico o anche aperto
il caso ai cani e quello capisce che
deve fare il giro sono nella cacca ecco
mazzo ecco magari i cani la prossima
volta li lasciamo dove erano solo se i
colpi sfrutta lì perché poi non so non
so dove che vado qua per messico allora
amici qua siamo ritornati mis en el ok
siamo ritornati nel coso della polizia
quindi va bè vestito far fuori per forza
meno male finalmente che avevo trovato
ski 15 colpi che bello sprecarli subito
proprio sono proprio contento ma questa
è un'altra fa ma lo è diventato zombie
anche mio amico da dove che finale
brutto eh vabbè che succede lì che
schifo e mi sa che c'è un po di gente
perfetto quello che poteva succedere
successo becca testa bomba
anzi se dio vuole facciamo saltare in
aria pure gli altri aspetta
buongiorno
beh è andata bene fratello mi dispiace
un sacco
allora armadietti armadietti armadietto
3f quindi devo andare dagli armadietti
sicuro è mio amico il mio amico sarà
morto spe fermi o si è trasformato anzi
guardalo da mi dispiace un sacco
mi dispiace tantissimo raga ok ho la
chiave adesso per aprire c'è questa
portata si apriva davanti a parte nomi
di corto dove fosse priva porcu schifo
in terra
cosa ci fa lì cosa ci fa qui lui allora
innanzitutto la cosa che volevo vedere
ecco qua
porca vacca la stessa cosa dove posso
infilarci quei tre ecco qui sotto c'è
qui qui dietro che c'è ma c'è un'altra
ancora mancavano le zone nascoste a
voglio veramente sprecare un proiettile
per questo sta la partita no quanta roba
che nuova de figo va bene scendiamo
figurati questo vuol dire che per torna
indietro devo farmi in giro il mondo
scommetto ci mancava solo questo let's
go on
vediamo cosa ci trovo mai in in qua
dentro ua un'altra pianta quest'anno al
calo sto combinando pio miliardo di
piante da combinare però proietti non ne
ho mai è l'altra parte dell'elicottero
figo quindi niente devo girare tutto
perché ancora
ho deviato l'acqua sono un figo ah ok ho
spento l'elicottero adesso passata
dentro perfetto ho fatto un casino per
tornare indietro
cristo santo
porca di una vecchia che è che che guai
a chiamarle tu sei hulk o facciamo
valere le ammette che ciò che è uscito
pensavo non uscisse cos'è sta roba aiuto
e vabbè ma cos'è cosa è fortissimo ok lo
devo solo stordire perché non puoi fare
altro va bene
simpatico molto simpatico via via via
via vivere a dio quanto devo correre con
la chiave trifoglio normale vado subito
la porta che si apre con la chiave
trifoglio chiave questa però ci abbiamo
che è interessata da qualche parte ok
assieme dietro la porta con la chiave
del cuore quindi perfetto o un oggetto
utile una h che ho capito cosa mi serve
e perle nella libreria mi serve per
infilarla nel no no no no no no no no no
porca a nano zombie normale se fosse
chissà chi devo tornare tutto a sinistra
se riesco aspetta
via via via via perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto perfetto mentre tre
metri
il vero non c'è nessuno perfetto vai che
anziché mi sembri giocar ad alien
c'è gente che cammina a caso mai buttalo
ok
senti che cammina esattamente qui a
destra orribile dov'è schifoso l'aido
pezzenti guardalo guardalo com'è
possibile
no non ci credo è dato non può passare
c'è buco
volevi passare franco guardali è bassa
cima a via via ma c'è un altro piano che
non avevo visto fatale porca vacca non
avevo proprio vista sta gente bene così
fammi controllati questa c'è
qualcos'altro si magazzino alla s
eccolo là come franco infatti in vari
spazi tuoi che di qua questa aperta uno
zombie in un gioco di zombie non avrei
mai detto
c'è lo zio che probabilmente sta
arrivando quindi prima ci muoviamo
meglio ok combina ingranaggio del
qualcosa mi serve per metterlo nella
stanza di prima il problema è che adesso
c'è il tipo quindi non ci posso andare
vabbè chissenefrega via via via via
siamo qua
avevo già visto che che serviva per
entrare qua quindi perfetto usa molto
bene
la scala white skull e non sono anche le
portano basta che trova la chiave a
cuore da qualsiasi parte bassa non c'è
quel tipo li fanno vedere che cosa serva
un'altra scatola non riesco a
raggiungerla c'è la campana li
ingranaggio piccolo a ok lo metto di
saldo praticamente lo prendo lo ammetto
18 lisi speriamo che il tipo non venga
qua dentro perché se vi è qua dentro e
non so come andarmene se non so come
stordirlo per andarmene non ho neanche
più colpi l'altro lo metto qua fuori
prima questo ho attivato cose ma non so
cosa sia proprio questo volevo fare io
attivato l'orologio va beh è proprio
quello che non dovrà succedere un casinò
c'è sto casino per farmi cadere la
scatolina tutto sto casino per la
scatola ci fa ridere starò a scrivere un
rapporto non spero che non abbia sentito
l'altro tizio teoria che già che va beh
per chi è quello lì scusami ok
componente elettrico apri apri a esami è
scusata ok c'è un altro uguale a quello
di prima scommetto infatti ottieni la
tessera del parquet hockey devo tornare
indietro adesso nel parcheggio per farvi
dall'attesa regolo morto cibo ma prima
di tornare nel parcheggio devo
assolutamente vedere cosa c'è qua dentro
nel portagioie perché ho la gemma che
l'avevo trovata 60 anni fa qua dentro
conviene perfetto apriti
wow
vedi ragazzi questa è la seconda episodi
di residenti vol
me lo sto veramente gustandola gustavo
quindi niente spero piace anche a voi
prossimi episodi riesce il giovedì
ricordatevi esce il lunedì e giovedì
sondando avanti abbastanza veloce ma
perché sto cercando di tenere i momenti
più belli
dunque ragazzi io spero che vi sia
piaciuto ma se non siete christie's
chiede e noi come sempre sentono oltre
il comando che ho trovato ci vediamo
non possiamo dare azione
[Musica]